außerirdisches leben endlich dingfest
machen die chancen dafür stehen gut doch
wie kann das gelingen die
us-raumfahrtbehörde nasa hat genau dazu
jetzt einen konkreten plan vorgelegt
denn man will bestens vorbereitet sein
wenn man außerirdisches leben endlich
auf die schliche kommt und dafür gibt es
immer mehr hinweise steht die entdeckung
von außerirdischem leben also vor der
tür 619 future gegen drei mal pro woche
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur so
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen
die fachwelt ist sich sicher irgendwo da
draußen in den weiten des kosmos
existiert außerirdisches leben selbst
der nasa chef höchstpersönlich bill
nelson hatte vor einigen wochen
eingeräumt dass außerirdisches leben
denkbar ist konkret hatte er sich zudem
vor sichtungen der vergangenheit
geäußert und das auf spektakuläre art
und weise demnach hält er es tatsächlich
für vorstellbar dass es sich bei den
jüngsten ufo-sichtungen um raumschiffe
von außerirdischen gehandelt haben
könnte wir hatten hier paar klicks um
science im future darüber berichtet und
das war eine spektakuläre premiere in
solch einer deutlichkeit hat noch keiner
seiner vorgänger im amt diese
möglichkeit aufgezeigt sagte nasa-chef
kann bei zahlreichen ufo-sichtungen
immer noch nicht erklärt werden wer oder
was wirklich dahinter steckt es gebe
schlichtweg keine erklärung dazu nelson
dann bin ich denn behaupten zu können
dass die erde der einzige ort ist an dem
eine lebensform lebt die so zivilisiert
und organisiert ist wie die unsere
einmal deutlich dass nicht
auszuschließen ist dass es einen
zusammenhang zwischen militärischen
sichtungen von unidentifizierten
flugobjekten ufos und der suche nach
außerirdischen leben geben könnte jetzt
gehen die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler der nasa woran schon
weiter sie haben nun einen plan
entworfen mit einem großen ziel
außerirdisches leben nachzuweisen zu
quantifizieren und zu beschreiben in
sieben schritten sondern also mithilfe
der kompetenz auf live action scale nach
möglichen anzeichen und hinweisen nach
außerirdischen gesucht werden wie genau
kann man sich diesen sieben stufen plan
vorstellen und wie realistisch ist es
wirklich damit außerirdischen leben
endlich auf die spur zu kommen die
spannende antworten auf all diese fragen
und natürlich noch viel mehr gibt es
jetzt hier bei clixoom science in future
der name des plans conference of life
tactician kurz kommt steht für vertrauen
in die entdeckung von leben der nasa
chef wissenschaftler jeff green fast das
folgendermaßen zusammen eine solche
skala wird uns helfen zu verstehen wo
wir bei der suche nach leben stehen und
welche fähigkeiten missionen und
technologien uns bei dieser suche helfen
die beteiligten fachleute sind
optimistisch dass noch diese generation
bei genau diesem projekt erfolgreich
sein könnte die nase hält es für wichtig
die öffentlichkeit mit in die
überlegungen der wissenschaft
einzubeziehen damit ein
gesellschaftlicher dialog zum thema
entstehen kann denn die suche nach
aliens sein zitat vielfältig und
kompliziert und bietet zudem ein hohes
potenzial für sensationsmeldungen stufe
1 des plans sieht vor hinweise auf
lebens signaturen zu finden wie
beispielsweise ein biologisch relevantes
moleküle die rede ist also von einer
potenziellen bio signatur außerhalb der
erde gemeint sind hier mit verbindung
chemische elemente physikalische
vorgänge oder anzeichen von aktivität
die einen biologischen ursprung haben
können aufgespürt werden könnte eine
solche potenzielle bio signatur
außerhalb der erde mit der hilfe eines
rovers eines weltraumteleskops oder
eines anderen technischen geräts sobald
dieser erste step gelungen ist geht es
in den folgenden drei schritten darum
die region in der die bio signatur
gefunden wurde genauer zu analysieren
konkret muss es in der zweiten stufe des
sieben stufen plans darum gehen die
gefundenen bio signatur auf die nächste
stufe zu heben doch dafür muss zunächst
sichergestellt werden dass sie eben
nicht durch eine kontamination der
instrumente auf der erde beeinflusst
wurde gemeint ist damit dass eine
planetarische lebensform auf einen
anderen weltraum körper übertragen wurde
beispielsweise durch raumanzügen die vor
dem abflug von der erde auf einen
anderen planeten nicht richtig gereinigt
worden sind durch die zweite der
insgesamt sieben stufen soll also
sichergestellt werden dass es sich nicht
um irdische lebewesen handelt die von
der erde stammen und aus versehen zu
ihrem fundort übertragen wurden erst
wenn eine solche kontamination sicher
ausgeschlossen werden kann geht es
weiter mit der dritten stufe hier geht
es dann um die region und das umfeld in
dem der hinweis auf außerirdisches leben
aufgespürt wurde wirkt es bewohnbar oder
nicht wie steht es um klima temperatur
und licht könnte die umgebung also
tatsächlich biologisches leben
beherbergen das vorhandensein von methan
und sauerstoff könnte ein wichtiger
meilenstein der stufe vier sein da heißt
es ein weiteres signal zu entdecken und
das unabhängig von der ersten bio
signatur die aufgespürt werden konnte
erst dann geht es weiter mit level 5 so
wird schnell klar dass das schwierigkeit
level immer weiter steigt und nicht zu
leugnen ist dass vor allem die letzten
drei stufen schwer zu knacken sein
werden hier wird nun geprüft ob die
signale tatsächlich biologischen
ursprungs sind alle alternativen
möglichkeiten müssen durch messungen und
beobachtungen widerlegt werden stufe 6
erfordert dann eine weitere überprüfung
jetzt ist es an der zeit dass andere
forschende mit instrumenten die
gemachten beobachtungen nachvollziehen
können dann endlich angekommen auf der
letzten stufe der skala dazu sagt die
nasa-wissenschaftler mary voltec die an
der studie beteiligt war mit jeder
messung erfahren wir mehr über
biologische und nicht biologischen
planetare prozesse die suche nach leben
außerhalb der erde erfordert eine breite
beteiligung der wissenschaftlichen
gemeinschaft und viele arten von
beobachtungen und experimente
gemeinsam können wir stärker in unseren
bemühungen seien nach hinweisen zu
suchen dass wir nicht alleine sind hier
müsste der bund also noch einmal
bestätigt werden durch weitere
untersuchungen müsste das ergebnis also
noch einmal verifiziert werden denkbar
wäre dass beispielsweise wenn eine
weitere mission gleichartigen
lebenszeichen vor ort aufspürt die
bisherigen ergebnisse müssen also von
unabhängigen fachleuten untersucht
werden erst dann kann die existenz
außerirdischen lebens bestätigt werden
und das ist dann die finale stufe nummer
7 und das ganze kann schon begonnen
werden bei der mission des presse wie
und wo was ja seit anfang diesen jahres
2021 im seo krater auf dem mars nach
spuren von leben sucht gut denkbar wäre
es dass der rover bei seiner suche auf
biologische merkmale stößt das wäre dann
stufe eins laut stufe 2 müssten diese
merkmale dann daraufhin überprüft werden
ob eine irdische kontamination vorliegt
erst wenn das ausgeschlossen werden kann
geht es weiter mit ebene 3 bereits jetzt
wissen fachleute dass auf dem roten
planeten so genannte lacoste rische
karbonate vorkommen gesteine die auf die
frühere existenz von seen oder anderen
gewässern hinweisen so jedenfalls auf
der erde ist das der fall zudem
enthalten solche kamera oft bio
signaturen von verstorbenen lebewesen
falls das eintreten würde wäre level 3
des plans erreicht die proben die der
rover sammelt müssten dann von
unabhängigen wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftlern noch einmal genauer ins
visier genommen werden ebene sechs wäre
dann erreicht wenn verschiedene
forschungsteams unabhängig voneinander
beweise von leben bestätigen könnten für
den finalen set stufe 7 wurde dann eine
mission zum mars starten und dort in
einer anderen region nach leben so die
nasa wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler erhoffen sich durch
diesen sieben stufen plan dass die
gesellschaft zitat vernünftige
erwartungen an die frühphase stellt und
fehlstarts einkalkuliert dazu sagt die
nasa astrobiologin mary yoytek bis jetzt
haben wir die öffentlichkeit darauf
vorbereitet dass es nur zwei
möglichkeiten gibt es ist leben wo das
ist kein leben doch wir brauchen einen
besseren weg um die aufregung über
unsere entdeckung zu teilen um zu zeigen
wie jede entdeckung auf der nächsten
aufbaut damit wir die öffentlichkeit und
andere wissenschaftler mit auf die reise
nehmen können zudem betont dass nasa
team auch dass der neu entwickelte
sieben stufen plan so nicht in stein
gemeißelt zeit ganz im gegenteil dazu
nasa-chef wissenschaftler james quin ein
diskurs innerhalb der
forschungsgemeinschaft soll helfen die
scala zu modifizieren oder zu ersetzen
denn so kann die anwendbarkeit bei der
suche nach beweisen von außerirdischem
leben gewährleistet werden ok
die nasa wird also konkreter sie rechnet
mit dem baldigen auffinden von
außerirdischen leben zb eben durch mars
rover oder durch das neue james webb
weltraumteleskop
und dass auch hier es sind spuren von
leben auf enceladus entdeckt worden sagt
eine neue studie anklicken anschauen und
abonnieren bis dann bleibt dran